[Musique]
marcia baila titre phare de la scène
française dans les années 80 une ode
enragé écrite et composée par deux titi
parisien au nom étrange pourquoi rita
mitsouko parce que c'est un nom de
toutes les rita rita hayworth guitare
noire et ses épis mitsouko qui est un
parfum de guerlain
catherine ringer fred chichin la
chanteuse et le guitariste duo constitué
en 1979 il y à 40 ans leur première
apparition à la télé c'est en 1981 un
radio crochet en région parisienne pour
musiciens amateurs et déjà le charisme
de catherine ringer
[Musique]
de la provocation de la dérision in
aironi mordante
la recette du succès qui jaillira trois
ans plus tard un premier album sorti au
printemps 84 et une chanson cachée en
troisième position de la face b
marcia baila les radios libres se
jettent dessus la télé suivra première
diffusion mais 84 un playback sur fr3
toulouse
[Musique]
le groupe amusé avec ses excentricités
et ses tenues mais cette chanson
intrigue gay et triste à la fois en
réalité un hommage rendu à une danseuse
argentine morte d'un cancer foudroyant
au début des années 80 elle était l'amie
et la preuve de danse de catherine
ringer et s'appelait marcia moretto
les
[Musique]
dont beaucoup
petit
quand je souris
le groupe tente bien apporter quelques
clés sont chanson gay qui parle de la
mort mes paroles lorsqu'on tend
l'oreille sont explicites
marcia baila est une oraison funèbre
complètement des joutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1990 aux victoires de la musique
marcia baila est sacrée deuxième
meilleure chanson de la décennie passée
le duo monde sur seine et au milieu de
l'interprétation
un clin d'oeil à marcia moretto
[Musique]
k
c'est bien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore marcia baila reste le
titre le plus marquant d'un groupe
devenu mythique
[Musique]